And now let's look at the second
possible write-update optimization,
which is about reusing
the number of bus writes.
So after we added our dirty bit,
what we got is that the memory
now gets relatively few writes.
Only those writes that
are coming from replacements and
also the memory no longer needs
to respond to all the reads, but
the bus still gets all of
the traffic for all of the writes.
Every single write will need to go
on the bus and broadcast the value.
So now the bus, which sees all of
the writes will become the bottleneck in
the system, because every single
write from every single core ends up
going to the bus and
the bus can only take so much.
The bus broadcasts for writes that
are needed to update other copies of
the data, need to happen,
because this is a write-update protocol.
It needs to update other copies of
the data, but the optimization we
can do is about the writes that
do not need to update anybody.
So we will add another bit called the
shared bit to each block in each cache
and that bit will tell us, whether
the block is shared with others or not.
Let's see how things would work.
Suppose we read A here.
We get this valid not dirty,
but for the shared bit,
we need to know whether others
also have this block or not.
For this purpose,
we add a line to the bus.
When our read goes to memory,
other's snoop this read and if they have
the same block in the cache,
then they pull the shared line to one.
If nobody pulls the shared line to one,
then it will remain at zero.
So for this particular block,
because this is the first read,
nobody pulls the shared line to one,
so the block we know is not shared.
This is the tag and
let's say, we're at six.
Now let's see what happens when
this processor writes to A, and
let's say puts a value of 17 there.
It's a miss, we wrote us both
the write and the value.
The first time and
we see now that somebody is writing and
this cache here, snoops that write and
does two things.
One, it now knows that
the block is shared,
because somebody is accessing it now.
Second, it updates the value.
Third, it pulls this line to 1, so that
this cache knows the block is shared and
now it has the block in the dirty
state with a value of 17.
So far, this has behaved exactly as
it should without the shared line and
without the shared bit.
So what's the benefit
of the shared bits?
Well, the benefit is
that now this cache,
if it wants to write again,
it sees that the shared bit is one,
which means that it does need
to broadcast same as before.
So the broadcast will happen exactly
as before, if there is another sharer,
because we need to update that sharer
to the new value for the data.
The benefit of the shared bit
is in that, if this block reads,
let's say, B and gets a value of two
here and it's valid and it's not dirty.
And it sees that so far nobody has B,
so sharing is zero here.
And then once you write five to B,
it checks the shared bit here.
And because we know that nobody else has
this block, we can write the value here.
Make the thing dirty, because
the memory's no longer up to date, but
because the shared bit stays at zero.
Meaning, we are the only one who has it.
We don't do a bus right here.
So as long as some block is
being accessed only by one core,
it's no longer going to
broadcast all of the writes.
Meanwhile, this core could be
having in a non-shared state,
for example, block C and
it can write anything it wants there.
Can write 17, then 65, etc.
So B and C, because they belong
to only one core at this time
will not do bus writes,
while A will do bus writes.
So we still get the write optic
behavior when there is sharing, but
now we avoid writes going to
the bus when there is no sharing.
This can happen a lot, for example,
B could be something that belongs
to the stack of core zero.
C could be something that is
on the stack of core one.
So naturally, we will be just pushing
and popping things to our own stack and
never really needing to broadcast
the updates somewhere else.
But for data that is actually shared,
we still get exactly the same
write update behavior as before.
So this optimization will save
us a lot of writes on the bus.
It will save us all the writes that
are not necessary to maintain coherence
among multiple copies of the same
block in different caches.